la chronique de l'environnement à
présent bonsoir sofia bonsoir on parle
d'un nouveau type de déchetterie à
trappes qui a vu le jour il ya à peu
près trois mois
cela s'appelle une déchetterie mobile
toutes les deux semaines pendant une
journée des bennes sont installés sur
l'ancien parking de la poste face à la
rn10 et en présentant un document qui
justifie qu'on a fait de bien à trappes
on peut déposer ses encombrants des
déchets verts du tout venant des gravats
des déchets électroniques aussi pour en
discuter avec nous lucien le gay doit
bonsoir mon choix vous êtes donc adjoint
au maire à trappes en charge de la
qualité de la vie et de l'environnement
vous avez donc été obligé de trouver une
solution
en fait parce que vous êtes vous vous
êtes retiré de la déchetterie de trappes
et l'encours en fait c'est ça c'est une
gestion intercommunale
ils sont le plan financier ça ne
correspondait pas ça ne correspondait
pas du tout à une équité militer ça
revenait trop cher voilà voilà pourquoi
pourquoi notre fréquentation était
insuffisante
au cours d'un au cours de l'année
dernière on a eu environ 2000 personnes
qui sont rendus à la déchetterie et
rappelle encore à l'époque et par contre
ils encourent avait six mille personnes
donc à budget partagé il y avait un
moment donné
le budget était coupé en deux il n'y
avait pas de proportionnalité en
fonction facile parce que ça appliquée
que dans cette déchèterie fixe qui est
la zone industrielle partie ils
encourent sept déchetteries n'avait pas
de statistiques très président qui vient
de lui nous de l'eau des communes parce
que enfin il ya cette est limité aux
deux villes à une personne qui
n'appartenait pas à ces deux villes ne
pouvait pas déposé comme d'ailleurs dans
le cadre de la déchetterie mobile donc
en vous rende compte que c'était trop
cher vous vous êtes dit on va trouver
une nouvelle solution
et cette solution c'est cette déchèterie
mobile pourquoi alors lorsqu'on a on
s'est trouvé en fin de contrat puisque
on avait une convention sont trois ans
on s'est trouvés donc au moins deux mois
d'octobre ils s'étaient date à date
c'est le 5 octobre 2009 qu'on a commencé
l'expérience à elancourt on n'a pas
enlevé pour que la convention en concert
automatiquement avec la ville
d'elancourt ne recevait plus il est
rapide ce qui était tout à fait les
trouver une solution mais celle là est
un peu particulière elle et elle est
particulière mais elle elle répond
d'ailleurs à un besoin effectif puisque
ont été sollicités par par certaines une
certaine population et on s'est rendu
compte par contre parce que nous on
avait les origines de des personnes qui
menaient à la déchetterie et on s'est
rendu compte qu'ils venaient en fait des
trois zones pavillonnaires de trappes la
boissière le
le village la cité de nouvelles et
j'aurai le gars a bien confirmé un petit
peu si vous voulez que c'est qu'ils sont
plus proches de donc l'ancienne poste là
où se situait alors et il fallait aussi
trouver un site
s'il fallait un minimum de surface on
avait pour nom n'a pas beaucoup ou on
l'installé sur l'emplacement du marché
qui est près de la merise mais le samedi
yamar fait donc c'était c'était pas
possible là où il fallait trouver une
une surface dans la zone d'activités de
trappes locaux ce qui n'a pas été le cas
donc on avait plus c'est que plus que ce
soit là et finalement c'est pratique
parce que c'est à peu près au milieu de
la vie vous casser ça c'est pour le ces
trois zones qui sont des apporteuse ça
se trouve d'une façon très santal et
quelque part on a on a on a bien le
résultat de ce qu'on a de la démarche qu
on a lancé ça fonctionne véritablement
ça fonctionne aujourd'hui ce système là
il n'y a pas de d'ordures qui
fleurissent de déchets un peu partout
dans le monde les gens ont pris le bon
réflexe toilettes ce qu'on craignait
bébé en fait c'est ce sont des déposants
motivés donc y
il répondait bien il répondait bien ce
qu'ils font mais on s'en suit on s'est
assuré à m le nombre de domaines qui
correspondait aux différentes catégories
que vous disiez tout à l'heure aux
différentes catégories
il me produis déposé qu'est ce qui
change quand quand on arrive dans cette
déchèterie mobile par rapport à une
déchetterie classique c'est pareil
elle s'était en fait c'est pareil c'est
techniquement on met à la disposition
des de nos concitoyens
des bennes qui justement correspondent à
ce que le ce qu'il dépose et on voit
bien là samedi dernier il y avait on a
par exemple on commence à rentrer dans
la période des plus ou moins des
rénovations
donc on a vu que là par exemple à ben la
benne à gravats malala vient elle a
tourné plusieurs scènes
ouais c'est une bonne affaire pour la
commune est ce que ces économies que si
oui ils sont plan économique
effectivement on est à va dire que quand
on va ajouter toutes les charges
on va voir ça un moment est à la 50
pensant de de ce que nous payons
antérieurement 50% en survolant compte
d'internet un peu plus ainsi fonctionnel
quoi ils 100 mille euros avec en partage
commun avec elle en cours et là on a un
budget de l'ordre de 80 mille euros
qu'on sera obligé d'ailleurs bonifier un
petit peu en fonction des rotation des
bennes ce plus on n'a pas ce que une
balle qui et 3000 euros et autour de
cette base il ya l'enlèvement et le
rapport d'une autre va vous avez pu
samedi vous rendre compte et fait qu'il
manque la bnda g de gravats avaient été
ans est enlevé et une nouvelle été
apportées çà c'est que de l'argent
d'accord l'ajustement nous sommes allez
vous voir ce samedi je vous propose de
voir le reportage qui a été fait avec
patrick gect dixmude
attrape depuis trois mois c'est le
ballet des bennes à ordures le long de
la nationale 10 un samedi sur deux
l'ancien parking de la poste se
métamorphose en déchetterie végétaux
tout-venant gravats et déchets
électroniques tout y passe depuis que la
ville s'est retiré de la gestion commune
de celle de trappes elancourt préféré
l'ancien mais on fait ce qu'on a parce
que c'était plus près de chez moi tout
simplement
et pourtant la déchetterie éphémère se
trouve désormais en plein coeur de la
ville
ce bricoleur vient pour la troisième
fois toujours pour la même raison
alchimie amener de la terre que j'avais
en trop et ça fait mon quatrième voyage
depuis ce matin plus ou moins kerriou
moins c'est ce que vont bien bien
souvent on fait la pommade d'été et qui
des fois les bennes sont encore hot pour
il reviendra dans quinze jours car il
lui reste encore quatre remorques de
terre une petite révolution pour les
trappistes une habitude pour la société
gestionnaire des déchets ces mêmes
principes pour toutes les autres
déchetteries systech effectivement
d'abord il faut trouver un lieu qui sont
à peu près adéquat qui permettent ces
manipulations de ben qui sont ses rêves
le lot commun chez nous mais qui pour
lequel il faut pas mettre en danger les
habitants et les utilisateurs environ 90
personnes utilisent ce nouveau principe
de déchèterie mobile en une journée
un concept qui est pour l'instant à
l'essai mais qui pourrait peut-être
devenir pérenne avec quelques
aménagements dans les mois à venir
elle représente pour la mairie une
économie de près de deux tiers sur les
deux cent cinquante mille euros du
précédent budget alloué à la déchetterie
classique voilà et si on parlait de 200
milles sur le plateau c'est parce qu'ils
aient une histoire de tva qui s'applique
et puis il n'y avait pas il n'y avait
pas variable puisque on n'est pas de
statistiques
c
donc on ne pouvait pas invoquer
d'ailleurs une une participation plus
précis parce que ça ça a posé que la
déchetterie est à un point de contrôle
fiable d'accord alors ils m'ont a vu
dans le sujet il ya quelques
inconvénients pour les usagers notamment
le fait que ce soit tous les quinze
jours c'est pas forcément pratique mais
si vous voulez si on regarde la
fréquentation à la quinzaine
il ya environ 80 à 90 personnes qui
viennent si on multiplie par les 26
séances qui sont proposés on arrive aux
mêmes chiffres que ce qui était en
fréquentation a attrapé l'encours faut
dire que les gens vont devoir stocker
chez eux si on invite monsieur dans ce
reportage avec sa remorque de terre il
va encore devoir revient elle encore
quatre remorques qui n'a pas pu faire
tout le trajet il va attendre 15 jours
oui mais si on me mettons que que
l'ensemble de la municipalité décide de
créer sa chaque semaine on va forcément
multiplier par deux le budget qui à un
moment donné aussi houphouët était aussi
de faire des économies donc forcément il
faut trouver une variable d'ajustement
c'est sûr on en voit bien là
les gros bourgs le gros problème c'est
les apports de gravats les autres on en
a pas il n'y a pas de remarques
particulières sont des bennes va
effectivement qui sont très hautes
pas forcément facilement accessible mais
les portes arrière sont quand même
ouverte
oui c'est ça ça change aussi le disait
aussi dans le reportage que cette qui
devait monter plus haut ça oui mais ce
monsieur ce qu'ils disaient c'était pour
sa terre médiateur on peut pas avoir de
benne à gravats plus haut tu oublies bat
s'est normalisée c'est du matériel qui
est que les entreprises de traitement
utilisent couramment donc on peut pas
s'est il est
ils auraient pu revenir une autre fois
afin refaire un autre tout puisqu'il y
avait la benne était à peine la deuxième
ben oui il y aura toujours ces problèmes
d'autres vous me les techniques ratio
est ce que le rap est la seule ville
sont fiés à utiliser ce dispositif ou
est-ce que d'autres communes
non non je vous n'êtes pas les premiers
dans les yvelines d' sur saint quentin
vous êtes les premiers mais dans les
yvelines
il ya quatre autres sites qui existent
dont on peut voir peut-être la carte à
l'écran à bréval saint nom la bretèche
noisy ou rocancourt mais alors eux ils
le font pas autant que vous en fait
c'est plutôt une fois par mois et s'est
pas autant d'échecs vous dont vous êtes
un peu les précurseurs sur une
utilisation aussi forte
vous voulez qu'on pense et on voulait
compenser ce qu'on avait ce qu'on avait
supprimé donc par ce moyen là
effectivement on la porte et on a
constaté parce que ça c'est important
que l'apport
effet à 80% par des habitants de
l'habitat horizontale alors que
l'habitat vertical de fait un apport que
quatre concentraient en vertical et
horizontal ça veut dire la différence
des bleus en gros le vertical ce sont
les bailleurs sociaux puisque trappe
nice est de l'ordre de 70 % de logements
sociaux
on peut dire aussi qu'il ya environ 10%
de promoteurs donc plus l'habitat en
accession et privé et le reste donc
c'est l'habitat horizontale c'est
d'ailleurs du palio sont les trois
principales zones dont je dis si tu es
tout à l'heure la boîte hier le village
et j'aurai le gard parce que les autres
ont leurs propres solutions pour gérer
leurs déchets avec les bailleurs sociaux
voilà c'est le bail et ça ça a été ça on
l'a on l'a on la travaille est très
fortement lorsque le 5 octobre 2009
la ville est entrée dans une phase
complètement nouvelle en vous en la
collecte orbite lui donc le be fluent ça
voulait dire d'un côté les ordures
ménagères et du tri fédérer et d'autre
part les dd produire aussi que la plus
de cartons les bouteilles de
minérale en bouteille de lait et autres
pour plus revenir juste sur le
dispositif qui est en test actuellement
est ce que justement c'est un test le
dispositif de déchèterie qui en place
lentement bon deal pour poulains pour
l'instant s'il voulait on fait pour
répondre à une demande
dire que ce sera pérenne c'est bon il
faut pas le dire at il par vox est un
test c'est intéressant qu'à un moment
donné va faire qu'on trouve
effectivement une solution
cette solution elle n'est pas du tout
évident parce que il faut pour
constituer une déchetterie pour la seule
commune de trappes fait pas forcément
évident il ya d'abord le conquis foncier
il faudrait peut-être la partager cette
déchetterie ses pensées avec la
aujourd'hui problème se pose parce que à
montigny par exemple yann déchetterie a
hélas en cours dont aucun n'a une manie
en a eu
voisin on a une donc à un moment donné
on va peut-être obligé mais c'est
coûteux mais ce serait surtout jour ce
type de déchèterie mobile ou vous
prévoyez derrière moment de
l'égalisation du fixe donc c'est
vraiment toujours quelque chose de
transition en fin de compte on va le
continuer comme ça puisqu'on s'est rendu
pour l'instant la prochaine fois ce sera
donc dans quinze jours puisque c'était
samedi ce sera donc un jour j'ai bien
suivi pour les habitants de trappes qui
voudraient déposer leurs déchets merci
d'être venu nous apporter ses différents
précision sophie on va juste terminer
cette chronique de l'environnement avec
quelques quelques dates l'agenda tout à
fait je vous propose plusieurs
rendez-vous alors le 4 et 5 mai
l'association sky en transition organise
des ateliers botanique au jardin
pédagogique les mains dans la terre à
magny les hameaux
vous pourrez découvrir les plantes
sauvages comestibles et médicinales ou
encore réaliser un potager mandala alors
attention c'est sur inscriptions avant
le 2 mai et si vous n'êtes pas adhérent
cela vous coûtera 10 euros ou 5 euros en
tarif réduit
le musée national de port royal à magny
les hameaux lui accueille la revue
jardin le samedi 4 mai à 14 heures
l'occasion de rencontrer les auteurs
comme michel racine qui est spécialiste
du tourisme desjardins en france et puis
vous pourrez aussi profiter d'une
dégustation champêtre de visites
associés dans les jardins de port royal
c'est gratuit mais l'inscription est
conseillé et puis les amis du parc du
perray-en-yvelines organise une brocante
au jardin et puis des ventes de végétaux
le mercredi 1er mai de 10 heures à 18
heures demain donc aux 24 chemin du
vieux moulin opéré en yvelines et puis
si vous aimez les insectes asiatique
aquatique pardon
rendez vous à la maison de
l'environnement de manier les armes au
l'exposition les libellules présente une
série de macrophotographie réalisé par
fabien viré de la société un sac de
france dans une démarche à la fois
artistique et scientifique du mardi au
samedi de 14h à 18h à partir de samedi
prochain
et c'est en entrée libre merci sophy
cette chronique est à revoir sur le site
internet de télé fils ainsi que
l'émission consultation libre équilibre
le mensuel de la rédaction dédiée à
l'environnement merci sophy